il y a une heure précise pour parler à
Fatou 4h du matin elle dort le matin
c'est impossible
quand elle se réveille c'est impossible
et le soir quand je rentre elle est déjà
en fait
je suis occupé là donc j'essaie de
l'avoir à midi voilà midi midi car je
demande des trucs donc entre midi et un
quart d'heure pour demander est-ce que
je peux faire la vaisselle ah bien sûr
est-ce que je peux il y a des courses à
faire est-ce que je peux faire la
vaisselle comment vas-tu chéri un petit
shopping j'ai un quart d'heure pour
demander ce que je peux faire dans la
journée bah oui
bien sûr c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne
notre couple
la meilleure technique c'est maintenant
c'est quoi quand il a pas fait beau
pendant un certain temps et qui
recommence à faire beau vous attendez
10h 10h30 du matin et là vous demandez
ce que vous voulez parce que c'est pas
trop tôt le matin parce que si il se
lève de mauvaise humeur il va t'envoyer
chier pourquoi tu as dit tu as fait tout
comme une gamme toi
[Applaudissements]
je crois que tu avais fait ton coming
out
c'est pas secret
tu disais quand je dors avec Jean-Claude
on préfère non mais je trouve que tu as
choisi pour le moment il a choisi
la saison voilà on se rappelle de te
voir voilà au Rambo synthétique hein
mais la technique universelle c'est
après le coin 2 minutes est-ce que tu
veux que je mette maintenant un jingle
avant que tu parles
allez-y non qu'est-ce que tu dis NON je
disais c'est après le coït normalement
excuse-moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Koh-Lanta il a soif
il a même ajouté
et tu pues de la gueule
excuse-moi fais-moi penser après l'amour
vous avez pas soif
[Rires]
tu es en train de dégoûter tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
avant avant avant avant avant avant
avant avant
[Rires]
il a des chaussettes de tennis ah il va
recevoir des lettres de alors mais c'est
un enfer
de tennis c'est une horreur avec les
trois bandes
à la maison il repart avec un t-shirt et
d'ailleurs il a ses stand de Man ouais
Stan Wawrinka qui est à la maison
actuellement parce que c'est
Roland-Garros et il m'en a ramené des
nouveautés